[Music]
they basically recorded like the
aftermath of them talking huffin and
puffin embezzle Britney heard it yeah
yeah Britney was like this I actually
stole the recording or fits fine I like
took her phone to the bathroom and I
sent it to myself okay do you not have a
passcode on your phone okay
James was like my best friend yeah and I
tell you I was with that man every day
we were drinking all night we were in
the pool we were you know hanging out at
bars and the Abbey and all these gay
clubs I didn't think I needed to save
myself from James well did you know he
stole the record oh yeah why would I
phone him we could I cussed him clean
out in the middle center like how did he
know about the recording you hold up
yeah okay so this was thing I do music I
record music music is my life so when
Jax came in I was writing music
I used my memo to record my music I
didn't have time to go oh let me check
the room for cameras and audio and it
just kind of happened so it caught the
caught our conversation not all of it it
wasn't like a long audio cuz I didn't go
that long so it was the beforehand then
they caught some before hands it's about
their weight
it caught some before and some after so
then did you stop the recording then and
then continue the recording like did you
know I don't want it as proof I guess no
so this is what happened after we're
done talking yeah I walk him out I go
back into my room I grab my phone to
keep doing the music alright and I check
my phone this is a long memo what's
going on here and I play it and then I
hear everything and I'm like man like I
can't believe this and I'm going back
and I'm playing it I'm hearing what he's
saying I'm like god I can't believe say
this by Britney I call it James that was
my best that was my best friend sure he
goes I have to hear this so then I let
him hear it on my phone didn't send it's
him then he goes to the bathroom with my
phone
Logan goes famous Houser from the butter
he comes back and goes dad I talked you
through from your production I got the
audio hope you're not mad me but I'm
really thankful that he told the truth
because people thought that I put that
information out there and I did it so
what was actually on this recording I
know people want to know and it I
Britney would have not have played
I wouldn't have talked about it and
honestly but he said what's the worst
thing he's said on that tape he said I
was you know the best he's ever had he
said Britney was getting weight he said
that he was pressured to marry her and
he'd never be marry her he would never
marry anyone doesn't want to get married
at all he said if it wasn't for Katy
living down the hall things would be
better because he would talk Britney
into doing things than for you but ok
with it then Britney would run it by
Katie and Katie would say like no like
not a good idea the action of it it's
just terrible to go situation it's not
offer to use protection I'm one girl and
I'm I'm hanging out with people who are
close in your vicinity or friendship who
knows what you're doing outside of me or
the deems you really get from women you
know what I mean
[Music]